Guten Morgen Linus. Na, irgendwie haben wir schon lange nicht mehr über Überwachung gesprochen.
Oh, schau mal hinter dir, ein dreiköpfiger Affe.
Guten Tag, hier ist Logbuch Netzpolitik, der mit Abstand unterhaltsamste netzpolitische äh Podcast, der von mir und Linus produziert wird oder heißt es Dinos und mir,
Wie heißt das immer, der Affe, der dreiköpfige Affe nennt sich immer zuletzt oder so oder zuerst? Zuerst.
An, wer's sagt, also nee, der geht den sieht ja noch nicht mal jemand. Der ist ja auch immer hier, aber der kommt ja immer nur so ganz kurz durchs Bild. Und wenn man sich umdreht, ist er weg.
Hm. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. So wie die ganzen Verantwortlichen immer so, die auch immer gleich wieder verschwinden, wenn wenn irgendjemand mal anfängt, mit dem Finger auf sie zu zeigen.
Naja, das werden wir jetzt mal alles mal ein bisschen genauer anschauen. Es sind eigentlich irgendwas passiert. Ich habe gehört, ähm.
Europa wie sagt man so schön, flext die Muskeln oder ist das äh ist das überhaupt ein Wort? Flexen?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bei dir im Fitnessstudio.
Ich kenne das eher aus dem Handwerklichen Bereich. Ja.
Mit der Flex. Wenn Europa mal mit der Flex.
Europa will jetzt mit der Flex.
Europa flext bei.
Bei Google rein.
Beiflexen. Das ist so ein schöner äh ein schöner Begriff. Das ist es gibt ja auch Bereiche, ne, also IT-Sicherheit ist ja dieses Jahr eher so ähm oder eigentlich eigentlich jedes Jahr eher so, wo man sich denkt, na ja
Vielleicht doch was mit Handwerk, ne? Das hat ja auch goldenen Boden oder wie man so schön sagt, ne? Heißt das goldener Bohnen? Ich.
Und wenn man so sagt.
Mit so Anspielung und.
Hast du halt mit Stück Metall, nimmst du Flex, schneidst das bei, schweißt zack bum, hält.
Ja
Das ist auch in Ordnung. Handwerk, wobei das ist ja nicht Handwerk, das ist ja schon fast wieder Industrie, je nachdem, was man da baut. Ähm Gärtnern. Wobei da muss natürlich im Winter schwierig.
Also jetzt als Berufe, die noch gehen. Ja. So, Gärtnern.
Ja. So. Ja dann. Die noch gehen, inwiefern?
Die gibt's jetzt noch, also die sind noch die ähm die machen noch Spaß vielleicht oder so.
Im Gegensatz zu jetzt politischer Berater oder so.
Politik IT Security, hm ähm.
Ne, es gibt Leute, die stehen ja drauf, zumindest wachsen immer wieder noch genug Leute nach, die der Meinung sind, das könnte toll sein, ja. Ja. Die haben noch Träume.
Ja, ja, nee, klar, ich sage ja nur, ich sage ja nur so vielleicht nächstes Jahr, Logbuchgarten.
Es ist ja wieder Spargelzeit.
Ja, schönes Laub einfegen.
Laub, genau, Laubbläser. Laubbläser Lockbuch Laubleser
Na ja, keine Ahnung. Ich da ich äh ich rede Quatsch. Äh wir müssen ja irgendwie so diese Anfangsauflockerung ein bisschen Scheiße labern, bis wir dann endlich zu den harten Kernthemen der des Netzpolitischen äh,
Geschehens kommen. Sollen wir also diese dieser.
Ja, machen wir, machen wir, machen wir. Ist gut jetzt.
Die EU hat nämlich auch einen Laubleser angemacht. Ich wollte irgendwie zum Laubleser kommen.
Ah, sehr schön. Ich fand ja das mit der Flex eigentlich auch sehr viel interessanter oder das kriegen wir bestimmt noch rein. Ja, weil äh wir wissen ja, äh,
aller Probleme anfangen ist ja der Google, ne, da kann man ja irgendwie Dinge äh suchen und finden, die einen dann entsetzen.
Und so geht's ja nicht. Und ähm nachdem sich schon die deutschen Verleger so bemüht haben, diesen Moloch äh in den Griff zu bekommen,
relativ wenig Erfolg. Muss jetzt irgendwie die Politik nachhelfen.
Also ich ich man sieht ja im Internet,
Da kann ich auch immer wieder nur das Buch ähm wie ist das Buch überhaupt noch mal? Das Buch von Tim Vu the kill switch, oder? Ja. Das Buch von Tim Vu äh äh lobend erwähnen,
indem er quasi so die Phasen eines neu entstehenden kapitalistischen Marktes oder eines disruptiven Ereignisses auf einem Markt schildert,
wo es nämlich darum geht so am Anfang, ne? Also wir wissen ja, der Wettbewerb ist ja der Wettbewerb ist ja das hohe Gut des Kapitalismus, ne? Das ist ja so die ähm die,
Kraft, auf dem das alles beruht auf dem diese gesamte äh Theorie
gebaut ist, weil es wird immer Wettbewerb geben und der Wettbewerb sorgt dafür, dass es zum äh dass immer das Beste bestmögliche Angebot.
Master Switch, meinst du?
Genau, ja? Wäre auch ein bisschen komisch. Ähm jetzt bin ich hier aus dem Konzept gebracht. Jaban Nachricht, anderer Buchtitel,
Ähm boah,
genau, der Wettbewerb als die treibende Kraft und die muss natürlich aufrechterhalten werden, weil ne, wenn's keinen Wettbewerb gibt,
ist schlecht und am Anfang eines eines eines entstehenden Marktes gibt es natürlich ganz viel, Wettbewerb und dann setzt sich irgendwann das beste Angebot durch und dann bleibt aber diese Vielfalt des Angebotes nicht bestehen, sondern es bilden sich Markt,
mächtige. Und das ist natürlich dann immer so, das ist eigentlich der der
Der Zielzustand, in dem alle diese Märkte immer am Ende landen, ne? Einer ist groß und kauft alles andere auf. Und dann hast du einen Mann Monopol und dann funktioniert deine ganze schöne Kapitalismus-Theorie nicht mehr. Deswegen haben wir ja auch so diese ganzen schönen ähm,
beziehungsweise deine Theorie, Kapitalismus-Theorie funktioniert schon noch, nur die Theorie, mit der du den Kapitalismus schönredest äh funktioniert.
Funktioniert.
Ja Kapitalismus funktioniert auch ohne äh Wettbewerb. Funktioniert sogar besser. Nur ähm man möchte das halt äh nicht aus ästhetischen Erwägungen. Und ähm dann sagt man, okay,
Wir sind jetzt Wettbewerbswächter haben und die sorgen dafür, dass ne jemand
dass dass der Wettbewerb erhalten bleibt, auch wenn äh was weiß ich, ein Amazon äh den gesamten Einzelhandel macht und wenn ein Google den gesamten Such macht und äh was weiß ich, ne?
Gibt's ja in anderen Bereichen auch, aber in anderen Bereichen kenne ich ihn nicht so gut aus. Ähm.
Und da haben wir jetzt natürlich dies diese Situation ist natürlich jetzt irgendwie auch bei diesem Internet geschehen, ne. Wir haben diese schöne Grafik, die wir die Frank
irgendwann mal hier Frank Rieger irgendwo mal ausgegraben hat, wo man so gesehen hat, das Internet äh vor zehn Jahren und heute, die tausend äh Besuch,
meistbesuchten Seiten und dann siehst du vor zehn Jahren oder fünfzehn Jahren siehst du so verschieden große äh Vierecke irgendwie so, ne? Und dann ähm,
siehst du halt irgendwie zweitausendvierzehn oder dreizehn, wann der zweite Teil kommt, siehst du irgendwie drei große, Vierecke und so ein paar kleine äh Punkte unten drunter, ne.
Weil das Internet eben größtenteils aus Google, äh Facebook und Amazon besteht.
Und das ist natürlich nicht gut. Vor allem, wenn ähm das international so ist
weltweit so ist, ne? Das heißt, es gibt jetzt einen ein Google und der hat mehr oder weniger weltweit das Monopol auf Suche. Es gibt da noch so einige widerspenstige äh Länder wie China und Russland, wo das nicht so ist. Ähm aber sonst
hatte eigentlich keiner mehr eine Chance gegen gegen diesen ähm,
Akteur auf dem Markt. Und da muss natürlich dann äh der Vorwurf her, dass diese Marktmacht missbraucht wird,
um irgendwie wieder Wettbewerb herzustellen. Das ist eine ähm das ist eigentlich ein,
das beobachtet man immer wieder, ja? Und das auch natürlich sehr große äh Konzern äh Gruppen dann eben
Zwangs aufgeteilt werden und genau davon handelt ähm das Buch The Master Switch, nämlich von Tim Woo, da kümmert er sich im Bereich der
TV-Kabel
Netzanbieter. Da behandelt er dieses Thema, ja? Das also anfangs gab's irgendwie ganz viele konkurrierende. Dann ist einer hat sich durchgesetzt oder zwei, die haben sich dann irgendwie gegenseitig alle aufgekauft. Das Gleiche war beim Telefon so, ja, dass es irgendwie viele lokale Anbieter gab und am Ende gab's nur noch irgendwie Bell und ATNT oder so. Ähm.
Und dann wurden die irgendwann wieder zwangsgeteilt
um wieder eine Konkurrenzsituation herzustellen. An in anderen Bereichen Mobilfunk zum Beispiel ist das so, dass ja die Frequenzen quasi unter der Maßgabe verteilt werden. Das ist so und so viele Akteure an dem Markt
geben muss, die konkurrieren und die sich nicht ähm die sich nicht zusammentun können. Also dieses Problem ist äh tritt in jedem Markt
Wenn so gut wie jeden Markt früher oder später einmal auf, dass dann irgendwann von regulatorischer Seite,
quasi die Marktmacht einzelner Akteure eingeschränkt werden soll, indem man,
wieder Wettbewerb erzwingt und das ist tatsächlich häufig über diese Aufspaltung ähm.
Von ähm Konzernen oder die rechtliche Entflechtung. Und womit sich jetzt das EU-Parlament auseinandergesetzt hat.
Ist, dass Google ja neunzig Prozent Marktanteil hat und man googelt eine Wettbewerbsverzerrung unterstellt, denn wer bei Google nach einer,
Einer Karte sucht der Welt, dem wird natürlich die Google-Karte angeboten. Wer bei Google nach einem E-Mail-Anbieter,
Sucht den Wirt selbstverständlich auch Gmail angeboten. Und,
Das äh kann man natürlich zurecht sagen, ist äh äh benachteiligt andere Akteure an diesem Markt. Signifikant,
Ähm unter der Annahme, dass alles, was nicht unter den ersten drei Google-Ergebnissen ist, sowieso irrelevant ist.
Wenn ich jetzt bei Google eine Weltkarte suche, ist tatsächlich Google Maps selber überhaupt nicht dabei.
Weltkarte ist auch ist ja auch wirklich kein Begriff aus dieser Welt, ne? Also.
Das benutzt man ja nicht mehr.
Ich sage nur, ne,
So einfach ist es ja nicht. Ich fand, ich finde auch diese neunzig Prozent Marktanteil finde ich irgendwie auch ein bisschen schwierig, ja? Also.
Also erstens ist das ein Marktanteil in in Deutschland, wenn ich das richtig sehe, das ist kein weltweiter Marktanteil,
ja? Äh gerade wie schon von dir richtig genannt, ne, also und ich weiß nicht, was noch mal gleich diese russische Suchmaschine.
Wir wissen auch, wie das wie das dazu kommt, dass die so eine große äh äh regionale Bedeutung haben. Das hat sehr viel mehr mit dem Staat zu tun, als jetzt äh mit den eigentlichen Suchmaschinen, trotz alledem es ist auch nicht so, dass man Google nicht hätte, eine,
ähm,
Alternative entgegenstehen können. Und dementsprechend finde ich das immer so ein bisschen schwierig ähm etwas, was eigentlich auf reinem Erfolg basiert,
Man ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt Google vorwerfen könnte, dass sie irgendwie, obwohl sie schlecht suchen,
eine Marktstellung haben und dass nichts an ihnen vorbeigeht, ja? Das ist ja nicht so wie äh die Post oder die Telekom, wo du irgendwie lange Zeit einfach gar keine andere Möglichkeit hattest, weil da gar kein anderes Kabel rangeht, niemand anderes dir den Brief ausliefern kann.
Das ist das ist dann die Spätphase. Das ist die Spätphase, äh in der wir jetzt noch nicht sind, aber
auf die läuft es natürlich dann ähm am Ende hinaus, dass sich der Monopolist auf seiner Stellung ähm ausruht
auf sein, ja, also in der Phase sind wir jetzt noch nicht. Und es ist natürlich klar, dass Google diese Position erreicht hat, dadurch, dass sie einfach,
die besten sind
in ihrem Dienstleistungsbereich. Also sie haben die jetzt nicht ungerechtfertigt diese Position, darum geht's ja auch nicht, sondern es geht ähm oder du kannst jemanden nur darüber kommen, dass du ihm einen Ausnutzen dieser Marktmacht unterstellst, ne,
Und ähm dann musst du irgendwann mit diesen ganzen ähm
Kartellämtern kommen und äh das irgendwie wieder äh entflechten. Das ist, ich wollte das, ich wollte nur dieses Problem mal darstellen, dass das
ein grundsätzliches ist, was in anderen Bereichen auch auftritt und was eben in verschiedenen Phasen ist. Du hast irgendwie Wettbewerb, dann setzt sich irgendeiner durch gegen die Wettbewerber, der ist der, weil er der Beste ist. Das heißt, er kommt verdient in diese Position und dann, wenn er einmal in dieser Position ist, kann er durch seine Macht äh diese immer weiter zementieren
und ähm ausbauen, indem er die eben
braucht. Und das ist der Vorwurf, der jetzt eben im Raum steht äh gegen Google. Wobei das natürlich ähm gerade bei diesen E-Mail und sonst was Diensten, die Google da noch anbietet, eher äh.
Ein kleiner Teil ist, ja, also der der die Großen das große Geld macht, Google nach wie vor durch Werbung ähm und die Werbung ist
dadurch gut, dass sie dir deine Suche kennen und ähm Angebote wie Gmail oder äh Karten und sowas sind ja dann eher ähm
keine primären.
Einnahme äh Mittel, ja, gemessen indem wie wie Googles Einnahmen sich verteilen über die verschiedenen Geschäftsbereiche.
Anyway,
Jetzt gab es eine ein Resolutionsentwurf der konservativen EVP-Fraktion im Europaparlament. Maßgeblich geprägt vom CDU-Abgeordneten Andreas Schwab,
und der möchte aber nicht von zerschlagen reden, sondern benutzt den Begriff des Anbandligen. Also das Entflechtens und ähm in dieser Resolution fordert also das ähm,
Das EU-Parlament, diese Resolution wurde dann auch angenommen. Ähm die Suchergebnisse sollten frei von Verzerrungen und transparent sein.
Und es handelt sich dabei um eine handlungsaufforderung an die Kommission. Das heißt diese diese Resolution ist erstmal vollständig ohne jegliche Bedeutung
Es ist nur eine ähm politische Stellungnahme des EU-Parlamentes. Der Name Google kommt da auch nicht drin vor, aber sie sagen halt
such große Suchmaschinen mit Markt beherrschender Stellung, müssen,
transparent und frei von Verzerrungen arbeiten. Und jetzt hatten wir natürlich schon längere Zeit mal darüber gesprochen ähm.
Dass man eben ein so ein Suchalgorithmus, der ist eine Verzerrung in sich. Der ist eine.
Eine Verzerrung.
Genau. Und wenn du den ähm offen legen würdest, ist dann funktioniert er nicht mehr. Weil jeder jeder Akteur in diesem,
gesuchten Netz sich auf diesen Algorithmus optimieren würde und dann wäre er kaputt.
Hatte das mal hier als Beispiel angeführt, ähm Jasmin, ne, diese diese das war irgendwie ja, ja, ein, zwei Jahre haben die es geschafft, ähm einfach,
Wir haben letztendlich auf, Personennamen,
Ihre Suchmaschinenoptimierung gemacht, sodass Sie die Ergebnisse so präsentiert haben, dass Google diese besonders ähm schmackhaft waren und äh relevant erschienen. Und plötzlich waren sie halt zu jedem,
Personennamen, in den Top ten oder Top five der Suchergebnisse,
Und dann hat Google spezifisch dieses Angebot diskriminiert oder derartige Angebote diskriminiert. Und ähm.
Mitunter machen sie es eventuell auch zum Beispiel bei Facebook,
oder auch nicht, ja? Ähm das weiß man nicht. Google muss auf jeden Fall im Interesse der Qualität der Suchergebnisse ständig spezifische,
Angebote vielleicht entgegen der den normalen Ergebnissen ihres Algorithmuses äh bevorzugen oder benachteiligen. Gibt's da auch eine sehr schöne ähm,
Anekdote in dem Buch von Erik Schmidt, How Google Works. Ähm wo also,
Warte war das oder Larry Page hat äh Larry Page hat irgendwie abends äh an seinem Computer gesessen und gegoogelt,
und hat irgendwie Scheißergebnisse äh gehabt, dann hat er die einfach nur ausgedruckt, an die Pinnwand gehängt und dran geschrieben, diese Ergebnis Results,
weil er eben äh.
Randbereiche dieses Algorithmusses gefunden hat, die eben zu bestimmten Such zu bestimmten Suchanfragen, zu Scheißergebnissen geführt haben. Dann ähm haben sich ein paar Ingenieure hingesetzt und haben,
Das verbessert. Ja und ähm die Ergebnisse wurden.
Die Ergebnisse wurden immer besser. Also der der Google Algorithmus ist nicht irgendwie sowas wie äh äh
Clown äh Google Algorithmus Punkt GIT und dann hast du den äh haste den kommentierten wo drinsteht, wie wie sie suchen. Das ist ein,
hochkomplexes System. Und natürlich korrigieren sie da drin für alles möglich und das kannst genau das kannst du eben nicht,
öffentlich und transparent machen, geht eben leider nicht. Und genauso kannst du gibt es nicht so etwas wie objektive,
ähm wie einen objektiven Maßstab für wie frei von Verzerrung ein Algorithmus sein könnte.
Ja also du könntest sagen, okay, wir machen nur Patchrank. Ja, also den nach Larry Page benannten Rank-Ranking-Ansatz für Seiten, die,
im Prinzip sagt, okay, eine Seite ist relevant, wenn viele andere Seiten auf sie linken.
Das war ja die ursprüngliche Idee.
Das war die, das war die die,
Durchbruch äh in der Suchmaschinenidee von von Google auf den auf der dann Ende diese letztendlich dieser Konzern zum Milliardenkonzern wurde.
Sehr einfache Idee. Gibt's übrigens eine sehr schön. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du auch in diesem Chaos-Radio warst, aber das kann man kann man ein Chaos-Radio nachhören, wo ähm FEFA.
Ja, ja, da war ich.
Genau Telefon anruft und sagt total krasse Idee. Die Idee finde ich gut. Äh Google heißen die. Das ist ein sehr schönes äh.
Genau, wir fragen noch so nach wie GUGA oder? Nee, GO, GLE?
Ja, da war das halt neu. Also da war das sozusagen nicht da, ne. Damals haben wir noch so alter Bisser und so ein Kram äh
Mietergärten, diesen ganzen Kram benutzt, beziehungsweise man hat eigentlich auch Suchmaschine in dem Sinne noch gar nicht so richtig für voll genommen. Ist eigentlich auch sehr interessant, also Google war nicht nur sehr erfolgreich. Google hat überhaupt erstmal die ganze Idee,
Einer Suchmaschine final, äh in die Welt gesetzt, also weil sie eigentlich das erste Mal wirklich gezeigt haben,
Sucher Algorithmus, zumindest für den Großteil der Leute viel besser funktioniert als zum Beispiel Yahuz Ansatz vorher.
Directory.
Skaliert hat mit dem mit dem Wachstum. Das war gut so für die ersten ein, zwei, drei Jahre, aber irgendwann war dann halt äh Schluss. So ein Telefonbuch des Internets. Wir haben ja manche deutsche, mittelständische Unternehmen dann auch mal wieder mal verkaufen wollen.
So Spammails. Ja, das ähm das funktioniert nicht. Also
Das ist wirklich sehr schwierig und ich freue mich halt wirklich, was hier eigentlich jetzt konkret vorgeworfen wird, weil.
Vorgeworfen wird, ist Tim, es geht nicht um vorgeworfen, dass äh wir noch, will noch ganz kurz das mit dem Algorithmus weitererzählen, weil der ähm.
Also als bekannt wurde, ich brauche nur viele, die auf mich linken, dann war natürlich die erste ähm die erste Methode der Wahl war, ich mache einfach ganz viele Seiten und die Linken alle auf meine eine,
Ja? Und dadurch äh bekomme ich einen höheren und äh dadurch werde ich eben dann äh steige ich in den Google-Ergebnissen hoch. Also wurde der Algorithmus so gemacht, dass man gesagt hat, na ja, nicht nur die Anzahl der Seiten, die auf dich linken, sondern auch deren Patch-Rank
spielen wieder rein. Ja? Und dann wurde halt irgendwann festgestellt, dass man diese Seiten untereinander aufeinander linken lassen konnte und so. Also,
Dieser Algorithmus ist seit seiner Existenz ähm in stetem Wandel ähm sich dagegen zu wehren, dass,
dass die Objekte der Suche ähm versuchen, sich auf diesen Algorithmus zu optimieren.
So gleichzeitig gibt's aber natürlich den Punkt, dass Google ähm nicht seine eigenen Ergebnisse,
jetzt gezielt ähm herabwürdigen wird gegenüber anderen. Und das ist ja auch
Marktwirtschaftlicher Sicht total sinnvoll, dass die dir jetzt, wenn du, wenn du Navigation suchst, nicht sagen werden, hier gehst du zu Bingo oder zu zu Nokia
Ja, sondern die werden dir sagen, hier äh bei uns übrigens direkt eingeblendet, das ist die beste Experience, die wir dir als Nutzer bieten können. Du hast die Karte schon direkt mit da drin.
Und jetzt könnte man natürlich sowas machen wie ähm hm Google dazu zwingen, andere,
Optionen auch anzubieten,
Also so was wie, na ja, man muss bei Google irgendwie sich ein Cookie setzen können, dass man aber nicht die äh die die Google Maps, sondern die Bingmaps haben möchte oder sowas, ne.
Erinnern uns an irgendwie ein fürchterliches Wettbewerbsverfahren gegen gegen Microsoft, die irgendwie auf den Sack bekommen haben, weil sie den Internet Explorer mit ausgeliefert haben mit
mit äh Microsoft Windows, ne? Also ich meine, das war so, die haben, die haben irgendwie einen riesen Terz dafür bekommen, weil
Weil äh weil Firefox benachteiligt wurde, weil weil Microsoft seine Marktmacht ausgespielt hat, dass nämlich ähm,
die Computer eben mit Windows kommen und dann war Internet Explorer drauf und dann brauchte keiner mehr einen Browser, weil war ja einer dabei.
Also diese, die um diese Argumentation geht's da, ne, da da muss kein, da geht's nicht unbedingt um Strafe. Wobei, da kommen wir nachher zu. Natürlich geht es denjenigen, die diese äh Resolution Resolution eingebracht haben, selbstverständlich um äh,
um Strafe
abstrafen und Schaden des Schadens an diesem Unternehmen zu führen. Genau, also man könnte gegen den, man kann gegen den Algorithmus dann spielen und man kann ihn natürlich auch clone
beziehungsweise klauen. Das heißt, du würdest im Prinzip den Kern deines Geschäftsgeheimnisses offenlegen. Also diese Forderung ist vollständig unrealistisch.
Und der ähm selbst der,
also selbst würde sie Gesetz werden in Europa. Ja, also nehmen wir mal an, ähm Europa sagt, sonst darf Google hier nicht operieren, ja? Wir,
ihr dürftet einfach nicht. Dann ist Google dot com wird von dort von von europäischen Festlands einfach nicht mehr geleitet. So und euer Datencenter äh schneiden wir hier die das Glas ab, was da reinführt und so, ne, dürft ihr nicht.
Ja, also in der würde Google,
letztendlich sagen, okay, wir verzichten lieber auf den gesamten europäischen Markt, als auf unser gesamtes Geschäftsmodell. Ja, also du hast ja, das ist eine Einbahnstraße kannste, kannste komplett vergessen, diese diese Idee.
Dennoch ähm wurde diese Resolution eben jetzt angenommen. Ähm.
Oettinger sagte dann unser digital Kommissar sagte dann ja Zerschlagung ist ja ein großes Wort, er würde eher von Auflagen sprechen wollen. Ähm.
Und man äh bis jetzt wäre ja eh nichts
geschehen, außer dass es eben diesen Handlungsauftrag an die äh an die EU-Kommission gibt und da wird auch etwas passieren in dieser Richtung, da wird es irgendwelche Formen von Auflagen geben, die so eine, so ein Teil von ähm Wett
Bewerbserhalt durchaus bringen werden
da wird es etwas geben, das ist ein äh das würde ich jetzt tatsächlich äh meiner Argumentation, dass das passieren wird, würde ich echt einfach nur auf äh Naturgesetze des Kapitalismus äh
fundieren an dieser Stelle.
Jetzt kommen wir aber zu dem Strafenteil, denn.
Lass mir nochmal ganz kurz was ein äh Pflichten, weil ich finde das in dieser ganzen Betrachtung der Marktmacht einer Suchmaschine auch noch sehr interessant. Ich meine
in den letzten Jahren haben wir es in gewisser Hinsicht als
hingenommen, dass Google so die die Vollzugmaschine in allen ist, was man so benutzt. Man hat so irgendein Device, man tippt eine Suche ein und dann kommt irgendwie der Google. So und das stimmt natürlich jetzt insofern noch, als wenn du einen Chrome benutzt, dass das da so ist,
ja? Auch wenn du da eine andere Suchmaschine einstellen kannst, aber natürlich wird der Google Chrome Browser immer mit Google als die Vollzugmaschine kommen
Aber auf anderen Plattformen ist es halt mitnichten so. Ich meine, Firefox mag jetzt einfach nicht mehr die Bedeutung haben, trotz alledem, auch da ist ja demnächst Google nicht mehr der Leefalt,
sondern eben Yahoo, weil ja Google sich das ja auch einkauft, diese Präsenz. Also diese Marktmacht, dieses so. Ich bin,
Ich bin die erste Antwort im Internet, da also einerseits muss Google sich das teuer kaufen,
Also teuer im Sinne von der gehen schon Milliarden äh äh jährlich für drauf. Andererseits ist es eben auch äh durchaus eine volatile Position. Also es ist nicht,
gesetzt, dass Google immer dieser sein wird, also auch jetzt zum Beispiel beim neuen,
Safari kombiniert ja auch Apple seine Suche da mit rein.
Und äh damit eben auch andere äh Suchmaschinen.
Apple hat Suche.
Ja, sie haben Spotlight. Das ist so ihr eigenes lokales Suchsystem, was dir aber dann zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt suchst, auch so selber direkt
Vorschläge macht aus ihrem iTunes, Vorschläge aus ihrem Podcast Verzeichnis, Vorschläge macht aus Wikipedia,
Ja, also da sind sozusagen die Suchergebnisse, die du jetzt so unmittelbar vor die Nase bekommst, äh auch schon leicht gefiltert,
und natürlich auch äh so was wie Siri auf dem iPhone, wenn du da halt sagst, sag mir, wo ist Restaurant X Y, dann kriegst du da keine Googlesuche mehr.
Das das wird nicht von Google abgewickelt, also diese Portale sind durchaus äh volatil.
Sieht man, wie Apple seine Marktmacht missbraucht.
Ja, das könnte man äh an der Stelle auf jeden Fall auch sagen, ja. Ähm das ist im Prinzip dann wieder dieselbe Debatte, wie sie schon mit Microsoft äh vorher geführt wurde.
Das ist das ist richtig.
Kann kann sogar sein, dass ihr dann irgendwann alle nochmal angelaufen kommen und sagen, oh Gott, ich will mein Google wieder haben.
Microsoft ist übrigens auch ein schönes Beispiel, ähm wo der diese Markt beherrschende Position dann irgendwann tatsächlich,
Zum Nachteil des Nutzers wurde. Ja, also ich der Marktanteil von Internetexflora sechs ist immer noch atemberaubend. Und das ist natürlich wirklich eine eine äh Schaden, der da entstanden ist. Der geht äh
weit über die Milliarden hinaus, den die Microsoft jemals verdient hat, ja. Ähm.
Schaden für wen jetzt?
Für für die gesamte Welt, also für für den einzelnen Nutzer, für das, für das Ökosystem, für den Standort Deutschland, das ist also, da ist alles, alles ist da dran kaputt gegangen,
Ähm,
Ähm.
Ich gucke mal, wie der Anteil gerade ist.
Ach ja, ähm,
Ich mache ja auch nur ein bisschen Witze, aber ähm bei Microsoft sieht man eben dann auch in der Spätphase führt das zu was anderem und dann äh natürlich auch wieder äh eventuell dazu, dass ein neuer Akteur äh auf den Markt tritt. Aber diese Debatte findet da jetzt statt. Ich wollte die
einfach auch mal so in dieses kapitalistische Naturgeschehen mit ein,
Betten. Ja, das kannst du direkt mal als Titelvorschlag hier mit in deine Liste schreiben. So, jetzt kommt der,
Jetzt kommt raus dieser liebe Herr Schwab,
der diese Resolution eingebracht hat ist steht auf der Paywald der deutschen Anwaltskanzlei CMS CMS hast,
Ähm,
und die wiederum ist tätig für den Verband deutscher Zeitschriftenverleger und er kassiert dort monatlich so irgendwie zwischen eins und fünftausendeinundfünfzigtausend Euro, ja. Der gute EU-Parlamentarier, den wir da haben, der Herr Schwarz.
Also er persönlich oder die Kanzlei?
Na, er, die Kanzlei geht, dann die Kanzlei arbeitet doch nicht mit tausend bis das,
Nee, nee, das muss ja muss ja offen legen, ne? Immer mal so einen Transparenzbericht geschrieben und da hat er gesagt, hier bei denen die berate ich in Beratung. Und äh da kriege ich irgendwie so und so viel tausend Euro im Jahr, ne?
Also offensichtlich zwischen zwölf und sechzigtausend im Jahr äh verdient er von dieser Kanzlei, weil er die berät. Und die Kanzlei hat natürlich ein relativ klares Interesse, äh wenn sie für den Verband der deutschen Zeitschriftenverleger arbeitet.
Ja, jetzt hast du äh Latein gesprochen mit äh mit mit französischen.
Ist äh die, die Inschrift im britischen Staatswappen lustigerweise.
Ja, äh.
Viel heiß wie äh verflucht sein wir böses darüber denkt.
Ist das nicht ein der böses da bei den.
Schelm ich kann nochmal versuchen dir eine original.
Die beiden Intellektuellen hier.
Beschämt sei, heißt es äh wörtlich.
Okay.
Wir sind jetzt ganz beschämt, weil wir, glaube ich, für eine Sekunde, ja, Entschuldigung, also.
Ja, nee, das finde ich nicht.
Dem Ganzen mal so eine kulturelle Bereicherung hier an der.
Ja, schöne kulturelle Bereicherung,
und dann? Also das das. So und jetzt wurde natürlich gesagt, ha ha ha, der Typ ist ja befangen und der will ja nur irgendwie Google einen auswischen,
Gleichzeitig gab es aber drei US-Befürworter, die äh also drei Leute aus dem US-Kongress die offene Briefe
geschrieben haben und gesagt haben, ja, liebes EU-Parlament, ne, dass er irgendwie nicht gut und äh müsst ihr mal irgendwie euch zusammenreißen so, ne? Ihr wollt da, ihr seid da antiamerikanisch und so, ne?
Und äh die wiederum äh standen auf der Playboy von Google, die hatten irgendwie insgesamt ein paar hunderttausend Dollar gespendet bekommen ähm von von Google für ihre
äh für ihren Wahlkampf, ne. Also man sieht da äh da sind natürlich ähm.
Wirtschaftliche Interessen.
Spielen eine Rolle.
Spielen da spielen ja die einzige Rolle in diesem Bereich.
Das ist ja wohl bedrückend.
Es geht hier wirklich um die Befreiung der Massen.
Ich dachte, es geht um Ideale, ne. Ja, also das ist eine das wird uns noch viele Jahre beschäftigen, dass das ähm,
irgendwelche Wettbewerbswächter äh sich darum kümmern wollen und das ist auch äh ist auch richtig und wichtig, dass sich da um solche Dinge gekümmert wird.
Ich weiß nur, tatsächlich muss ich ehrlich sagen, die Lösung nicht. Aber das ist ja auch immer das spannende an der Gegenwart, dass äh man die Lösung noch nicht kennt. Also deswegen ist das ja überhaupt interessant alles, weil äh die Lösung,
Ne, was man in der Vergangenheit gelernt hat, dass äh das kann man dann anwenden. Aber genau deshalb wird's dann auch nicht mehr debattiert.
Und äh ja das ist schon ganz.
Ja, dann debattieren wir das jetzt hier auch nicht mehr.
Heute erstmal nicht mehr, aber wir werden's die nächsten Jahre noch sicherlich debattieren.
Ja, ich denke auch, das Thema geht nicht sofort weg. So.
Ja, völlig überraschend.
Stellt sich heraus.
Stellt sich raus, die Bundesregierung weiß, und der BND wissen seit zehn Jahren Bescheid, dass wir äh überwacht werden. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen ähm,
oder nicht, dass wir überwacht werden, das wissen sie ja schon seit äh je her, weil sie ja die entsprechenden Verträge und Abkommen mit den USA,
Schon seit Jahrzehnten haben. Aber ähm bereits seit zweitausendfünf wissen sie, dass der US-Geheimdienst.
Deutschland noch über die Zusammenarbeit hinaus als äh Spionageziel geführt hat. Ähm und zwar hat der BND da im März zweitausendfünf einen Bericht verfasst, März zweitausendfünf übrigens noch Schröder,
Ne? Äh ab November zweitausendfünf dann Merkel. Ähm da haben sie.
Über ein US-Unternehmen geschrieben, das in Deutschland Hightech Überwachungsanlagen angeboten hat, die Audio- und Videoaufzeichnungen machen,
An denen hatte der BND,
Interesse und hat sie dann einem Labortest unterzogen und gemerkt, dass diese Geräte Gebäck dort waren und bestimmte Audio- und Videoaufzeichnungen offenbar an US-Geheimdienste weitergeleitet haben.
Ja? Interessante Parallelen hier. Erstens,
Sagt die Geschichte natürlich auch, dass der BND diesen Scheiß kaufen wollte, ja? Also man sieht, die die beklagen sich hier, äh wir wollten ähm,
Equipment kaufen, um andere zu überwachen und wir haben festgestellt, dass die, die uns das verkaufen, direkt mit überwachen wollen. Das geht natürlich nicht,
Ne, das ist ja, da haben wir letzte Woche schon sehr viel drüber gesprochen, sehr ausgiebig drüber gesprochen, äh,
Wie da diese Interessenskonflikte in sind und auch nicht nicht äh aufzulösen sein werden in naher Zukunft?
Andererseits äh
interessante parallele IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, zu dem ich mich hier jetzt bisher noch kaum geäußert habe, obwohl ich da schon äh einen Vortrag zu gehalten habe. Das werde ich also irgendwann mal hier einführen, dass ich mal was zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz erzähle. Ähm.
Im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz geht's genau darum, dass äh wir bestimmte mh,
bestimmte Equipments als deutsche Bundesregierung, als deutscher Staat. Ähm,
einer sei, also Exportregulation unterwerfen wollen und auch Importregulation, das heißt, was eine TKÜ-Anlage ähm,
kann jetzt, soll nicht mehr einfach äh von anderen äh,
Firmen oder von aus anderen Ländern gekauft werden können, wenn,
infrage steht, dass oder wenn die Frage im Raum steht, dass dieses Gerät überhaupt integr ist. Ja, also das heißt, äh.
Die Geräte, mit denen die deutschen Geheimdienste deutsche Bürger überwachen, sollen möglichst von deutschen,
Firmen hergestellt worden sein, damit man ausschließen kann, dass äh Backdoors äh von anderen Ländern mit drin sind. Ähm,
keine kein keine blöde Idee, ja. Also man könnte sich natürlich auch überlegen, ob man diese ganzen Überwachungsequipments einfach ausbau,
damit sie weder äh äh damit sie halt von niemandem missbraucht werden, denn es gibt halt einfach keinen wirklich sinnvollen ähm Gebrauch dieser Geräte.
Aber äh auch da kümmert man sich also drum. Auf jeden Fall hat dieser, der gute August Hanning, dass dann zweitausendfünf den Bundeskanzleramt gemeldet und dass es deshalb eine Meldung wert, weil es eben,
weil da drin steht oder weil damit,
wird, dass die Spionagebemühung der NSA eben über die Kooperation hinausgehen und zu sagen, hey, wir haben hier schönes Love for Intersep Equipment für euch, das ist aber auch noch sehr günstig im Vergleich zu dem
äh zu den anderen Produkten. Und ähm äh besser, ja? Dann ähm,
Das ist natürlich keine schlechte Idee, um andere Länder zu
zu überwachen, ne? Genauso könntest du zum Beispiel hingehen und als Nokia Siemens Networks äh ähm Mobilfunknetzequipment in alle Welt verkaufen und die zugehörigen Überwachungsanlagen,
Das wäre zum Beispiel auch äh interessant, das ist ja auch über Jahrzehnte geschehen. So sind sie ja denn auch zum Einsatz gekommen in äh verschiedenen Ländern, auf die man heute nicht mehr stolz ist.
Der berichtet vom dreiundzwanzigsten März zweitausendfünf, das äh dürfte ja dann noch Schröder vorgelegt worden sein. Da war er gerade noch so ein bisschen Kanzler für ein paar Monate.
Ja, ja. Genau. Und äh Steinmeier müsste.
Bisschen Außenminister gewesen sein.
Oder? War er doch noch, ne? Der Stein war ja, ich gucke mal. Oder war der Kanzleramtsminister? Ja, Kanzleramtsminister.
War der ich glaube, der Kanzleramtsminister, der wurde dann Außenminister erst mit Merkel, oder?
Ja genau, weil das war ja noch der Joschka, genau. Hm.
Ja, aber äh also das auch schon das die Ende der News eigentlich, ja. Also sie wussten's und äh oder sie hätten's wissen sollen und ähm.
Haben aber trotzdem erfolgreich die ganze Zeit behauptet, dass sie es nicht wussten oder zumindest keine Ahnung hatten.
Wir hatten ja keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich meine, wer liest schon Vorlagen vom BND? Du? Ach so.
Mir legen die ja nichts vor. Doch teilweise, ach so das äh kommen wir mal zum,
Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Die Bundesregierung möchte jetzt gerne Strafanzeige gegen Unbekannt stellen,
denn äh einigen Leuten haben Dinge vorgelegen
Ähm unter anderem Details als geheim eingestufte Details zum Absturz der Passagiermaschine MH siebzehn. Details zur Arbeit des Verfassungsschutzes,
Details zu technischen Ausrüstung des Bundesnachrichtendienstes. Ähm ich habe ja auch ein bisschen darüber hier gesprochen und die entsprechenden Artikel verlinkt,
da lag ja dieser.
Wovon reden wir jetzt von dem Alkohol oder.
Von dem Letzten. Nee, nee, das ist nicht nur Alconal, sondern da ging es, wenn wir vor zwei oder drei Wochen drüber gesprochen, da ging es ähm,
um diese Einkaufsliste des BND,
wo sie im Prinzip äh auf auf relativ vielen Seiten ausgeführt haben, für welche Projekte sie welches Budget brauchen und wieso. Na ja äh gab's da noch einige äh ausführliche Artikel zu. Ähm.
Und so.
Genau, da ging es darum, sie wollten gerne Zero Days kaufen, sie wollten sich gerne so ein äh Hightech-Mikroskop kaufen, mit dem sie Mikrochips bei der Arbeit zuschauen können, indem sie die Infrarot,
Strahlung, Rezipi, mit hoherzeitlicher Auflösung die Infrarotstrahlung aufzeichnen, die,
Ähm entsteht, wenn Strom durch einen Transistor fließt.
Ja, da kannst, das heißt, du machst so ein, du lässt so ein Chip arbeiten, taktist dein Mikroskop auf die gleiche Zeit, auf die gleiche, auf die gleiche Taktfrequenz wie der Chip oder natürlich eine ins Idealfall eine sehr viel höhere, ja? Und dann siehst du,
an welchem zu welchem Zeitpunkt welcher ähm Transistor in diesem Chip wie schaltet,
ganz, ganz fancy. Das wollten sie auch gerne haben. Wir haben da, wie gesagt, gibt's ausführliche Berichterstattung zu bei einigen dieser äh,
Artikel habe ich dann auch mal Journalisten ähm die technischen Hintergründe erklärt. Das ist auch geliebt ähm.
Und die Bundesregierung findet das inzwischen nicht mehr ganz witzig. Ja, der Steinmeier hatte ja jetzt das, auch das haben wir behandelt, schon,
Ach Quatsch Dallmeier, Altmeier, Altmaier, ne? Ähm hat ja schon vor einiger Zeit angedroht, dass da äh dass er da jetzt mal äh langsam,
Die Schnauze voll hätte das immer alles auf Netzpolitik org zu lesen ist und ähm.
Bist du erwähnt, der uns eigentlich nicht?
Weil es bei uns nicht zu lesen ist. Wir sind ja Nische. So und ähm.
Gas.
Dann äh.
Außerdem an uns hat das ja auch nie jemand geliebt, muss man ja auch mal sagen, wenn jetzt Politik Org sind die Sachen ja tatsächlich äh teilweise äh gezielt auch hingelegt worden dorthin. Ähm.
Ihr könnt uns auch mal was liegen.
Hör mal auf, ey. Nee, das ist immer so du musst diesen, also wenn, dann bitte per Post, also digital ist das echt ärgerlich.
Ach so, na ja gut, die über das Wie habe ich ja nicht gesprochen. Nur weil das das.
Ich baue mal nächstes Jahr baue ich mal so eine äh setze ich mal so einen äh.
Whistleblower Plattform für Logbuch Netzpolitiker auf.
Ja. Ja, dann baue ich mal so ein ähm so ein äh Global Leagues oder sowas, können wir mal aufsetzen, kein Problem eigentlich.
Eure Daten reinflexen.
Ich habe sowas auch schon, ich habe schon so eine Instanz, ich muss die Nummer noch mal ein bisschen pflegen. Können wir mal machen, machen wir nächstes Jahr. Dieses Jahr ist äh wenig Zeit lang, wenn wir dann hier äh,
Bücher oder Musik erwähnen, ja, dann könnt ihr das da in digitaler Form liegen.
Ach so, ich dachte, du.
Was ich fragen wollte, Tim, hast du schon diesen neuen Hobbitfilm gesehen? Nein, schon gut.
Ähm,
So, die Bundesregierung hat jetzt langsam keinen Bock mehr und plant jetzt also eine Strafanzeige gegen Unbekannten. Das ist deswegen interessant, weil.
Diese Details in Zweifelsfall von Parlamentariern oder deren Mitarbeitern.
Gelegt wurden. Das heißt, es gibt irgendwo Menschen mit einem sozialen Gewissen, die Zugang zu diesen Dingen haben, zum Beispiel äh so scheint es ja hier jetzt gewesen zu sein zu dieser äh Budgetplanung des,
des BND und die dann gesagt haben, das halte ich für,
so relevant, dass ich mich gegen diese Geheimnisse, gegen diese Geheimhaltungspflicht wende, mich über sie hinwegsetze und das irgendwie,
hier raustrage und der Presse gebe, weil ich äh davon ausgehe, dass dieser massive Ausbau geheimdienstlicher Fähigkeiten ähm,
Und des geheimdienstlichen Budgets ähm der öffentlichen Aufmerksamkeit bedarf. Ja, das ist ja eine Gewissensentscheidung diese Menschen da treffen.
Und ähm da hat die äh Bundesregierung offensichtlich jetzt nicht mehr so viel Bock drauf, dass ihre
Arbeit und ihre Bemühungen in diesem in diesen geheimdienstlichen Bereichen äh von solchen Gewissenstätern torpediert werden. Und jetzt wird's natürlich spannend, wenn sie wirklich ermitteln würden, wer es war, dann äh,
hieße, dass eben ähm ein Verfahren gegen Parlamentarier oder gegen dessen Mitarbeiter. Und das wäre natürlich spannend, ja? Interessant wäre natürlich, wenn die jetzt feststellen, dass das jemand von, von der CDU war,
ja. Also das ist schon ähm also es auch hier.
Das kommt ja auch in den besten Familien vor.
Ja, wobei die besten Familien, die findet man ja eher in anderen Parteien.
Nein, das liegt natürlich daran, dass wenn du so so engagiert regierst, ne, dann dann leidet natürlich auch die Familie. Das war jetzt ne, also ich meine, wenn man mit so viel Engagement und so viel äh Mut,
das Land irgendwie in Richtung Fortschritt führt und äh na dann bleibt natürlich das Privatleben ein bisschen auf der Strecke,
Auch das möchte ich natürlich sagen, es ist einerseits.
Also es ist entlarvend, weil wir natürlich dieser gesamte NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, der da irgendwie agiert und so nur aufgrund von ähm Whistleblowern.
Ins Leben gerufen wurde.
Und dass die Bundesregierung natürlich eigentlich von Whistleblowern profitiert. Gleichzeitig aber äh.
Ähm selber keine haben möchte,
auch ganz normal, also du willst ja auch keine. Du willst ja auch keinen Whistleblower, der hier irgendwie Sachen aus der ungeschnittene Podcast aus der Meta-Ebene,
rausträgt, um mal irgendwie der Welt zeigt, was hier überhaupt alles abgeht. So dass ihr keinen Bock drauf, ne. So und ähm,
gleichzeitig freust du dich über jedes Lied von den anderen, ja? Auch das äh normal. Aber natürlich,
weil es zeigt, dass die Bundesregierung,
eine ganze Menge Leichen im Keller hat, offenbar, die sie gerne äh dort drin behalten würde. Und ähm wir sehen ja auch zunehmend, dass im Umgang mit diesen ganzen Snowden Sachen,
diese Abhören unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht. Wir sind ja hier die Opfer und so. Ähm das schwindet ja immer mehr. Ja, also wir sehen in der in dem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, dass der jetzt immer das wenige, was die BND-Mitarbeiter im öffentlichen Teil äh,
sagen können, schon darauf hindeutet, dass ne, dass wir da jetzt dass diese Welt der Geheimdienste, da braucht sich jetzt keine äh Regierung und insbesondere nicht die Deutsche äh hinzustellen und zu sagen, wir sind aber hier die Guten oder so.
Und das das finde ich daran sehr schön illustriert. Wir werden sehen, äh wohin diese Strafanzeige führt. Ich fänd's natürlich spannend, wann, wann die dann eingestellt wird, ne, auf Mangel an Beweisen.
Ja, vor allem, ist natürlich sehr interessant, so dieses merkwürdige Verhältnis zu Whistleblowing, ne? Ich meine, früher war es so en vogue, das sieht man ja auch in den USA auch so
hier sie in Reporter, ja also der der Journalist, der so die Missstände aufdeckt, Spiegel Affäre et cetera, das war ja alles so
geht in die Unternehmen rein und und und zeigt halt mal tatsächlich wie es irgendwie ist. Das sind dann auch irgendwie
ja heilige Person. Ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es wird zumindest anerkannt. Es hat gesellschaftliche Relevanz
So, aber in dem Moment, wo es dann eben äh entsprechende Umtriebe im Staat äh geht so, da,
geht's dann halt nicht, da stellt man dann mal lieber eine Anzeige, so wie er jetzt auch gegen Snowden mit allen geschützten gefeuert wird, die sich nur in irgendeiner Form juristisch oder zumindest öffentlichkeitswirksam ähm aufstellen lassen.
Ist geht es einfach so ein bisschen in die falsche Richtung. Ich meine, ich kann das so,
vom Bauch her, klar. So, wenn man so Kanzlerin ist. Ja, und dann wird einem so das, was man so irgendwie für für richtig hält, so in der Öffentlichkeit kaputt gemacht. Das ist ja auch,
Ist ja auch irgendwie doof, ne? Ist ja voll, voll doof. Das äh und ich würde sogar den meisten zumindest,
Noch unterstellen, dass sie das ja irgendwie auch gut meinen.
So nach dem Motto so ja wir müssen da manchmal so ein bisschen flexibler mit den Dingen umgehen und so, aber das ist ja alles nur wir lieben wir lieben euch doch alle.
Die meinen das nicht nur gut, das sind auch die Guten.
Tief in ihrem Herzen sind sie die Guten.
Ist dir das mal aufgefallen, dass äh jedes einzelne Land dieser Welt ist die Guten.
Nordkorea.
Na meinst du, die haben eine Presse, die schreibt, wir sind die Bösen.
Ist doch, ist doch wirklich, also das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema, aber ähm kein einziges, kein einziges noch so böses Land dieser Erde hat eine Presse, die schreibt, wir sind hier die Böse und die anderen sind die Guten.
Zumindest hat sie die nicht sehr lange, ja.
Genau, die hast du halt nicht besonders lange, oder? Ähm insofern, das ist schon, das ist schon sehr äh äh sehr amü.
Ja, mir mir ging's ja nicht um die Presse, mir ging's um um den Staatsapparat, aber da hört.
Auch der Staatsapparat ähm
Also ne, dieses äh Star Wars in allen Ehren und so. Das äh höchstrealistisch, was man da sieht, ne. Es gibt eben die reinen guten und die Böse sind so böse, dass sie irgendwie so eine tode Stern machen, die sich und ziehen sich schwarzen Umhang an und rennen da rum und ne und haben irgendwie Ei. So, aber letztendlich ähm,
Ist das absolut unrealistisch, ne? In Wirklichkeit wäre der Böse nämlich, würde der nämlich auch sagen, ich bin gut.
So läuft die, so läuft die, so ist die wahre Welt. Da da sind beide die Guten. Es gibt keine Bösen. Es gibt oder es gibt äh oder es gibt keine Guten, je nachdem, was man äh aus welcher Perspektive man drauf blicken möchte. Ich würde eher sagen, es gibt keine guten.
Aber wenn sie so gut sind, dann müssten sie im Prinzip so einer ähm zu einer Berichterstattung von innen auch standhalten. Das ist ja wiederum die andere Argumentation,
Ja, wenn ihr nichts zu verbergen habt. Ihr habt doch sicherlich nicht vor irgendwas zu verbergen, oder? Also, das wäre auch mal äh schöne Argumentation, mit der man so die Bundesregierung mal so eine öffentliche Anfrage machen kann, ob denn die Bundesregierung was zu verbergen hat.
Informationsfreiheit, haben sie was zu verbergen und wenn die,
einfach, weißt du, die lavieren da seit Jahren mit ihren IFG-Anfragen rum, ja, ist ganz einfach eigentlich.
Sie was zu verbergen.
Ähm.
Wir müssen weiter.
Ja, wir müssen weitermachen.
So, jemand der auch was äh zu verbergen hatte. Ja.
Da gab's, gab's tatsächlich was zu verbergen, die die Funkzellenabfrage. Das finde ich übrigens, das muss ich jetzt echt mal sagen, das ist ein ein Erfolg, der,
Im Prinzip vollständig in meiner Wahrnehmung, auf die,
Äh journalistische Arbeit von Andre Meister zurückgeht, den wir hier sehen. Und zwar die Frage mit der Funkzellenabfrage.
Ähm wir erinnern uns an die beiden Großen Skandale oder die beiden großen politischen Themen, bei denen die äh Funkzellenabfrage eine Rolle gespielt hat, vereinmalt die äh der die Gegendemonstration zum Nazi-Aufmarsch im in Dresden. Ich glaube, es war zwei,
war da der, die äh
die Demonstration, die in Frage stand und dann eben die Ermittlungsverfahren zweitausendvierzehn, nee, das war zweitausendzwölf und die Ermittlungsverfahren zweitausenddreizehn, wo also die,
Demonstranten äh und Gegendemonstranten mit ein mittels des Mobilfunknetzes erfasst wurden,
Bewegungsprofile erstellt wurden und die den Demonstranten,
Gegendemonstranten, hauptsächlich richtete sich das natürlich gegen die Gegendemonstranten, weil man war ja in Dresden und da äh sind natürlich die Linken, die Bösen, auch interessant, ne, wie sich die
der Gute und der Böse. Das äh ändert sich äh mit geographischer Position. Ähm.
Und dann in Berlin ähm kam die Funkzellenabfrage ja zum Einsatz bei der Ermittlung des äh des Brandstifters, der hier über einige Zeit äh Fahrzeuge angezündet hat in Berlin.
Die Bösewichte.
Das war ja,
das war ja auch jahrelang ein böser Linker, bis man dann festgestellt hat, das war einfach nur ein ähm Apolitischer äh Frosti, der äh rumgerannt ist und halt irgendwie Spaß daran hatte brennende Autos zu sehen. Ähm,
So, in diesen beiden Fällen kam eben die Funkzellenabfrage zum Einsatz und führte eben dazu,
dass äh eine ganze Menge ähm Menschen da beifangen im Datenschleppnetz waren. Ähm im Rahmen polizeilicher Ermittlungen und ähm Schätzungen gehen ja dazu
äh über das äh oder Schätzungen gehen davon aus, dass ungefähr fünfzig Funkzellen abfragen pro Tag in Deutschland stattfinden.
So
Und das Problem dieser Funktion Abfragen ist, dass sie ja weitestgehend,
außerhalb eines rechtlichen Rahmens stattfinden. Ja, das wird einfach irgendwann gemacht und äh es gab auch mal irgendwie eine ähm Staatsanwaltschaft, die so gesagt hat, ja ähm.
Sie sehen da jetzt glaube, man muss da jetzt keinen drüber informieren, weil äh,
Die Staatsanwaltschaften eben davon ausgehen, dass es kein Interesse an einer Benachrichtigung gäbe, in diesem Fall.
Es gab da vor einiger Zeit schon diesen Bericht von Andre, der dann mal gesagt hat, so ähm im Schnitt wurde jeder Berliner im im letzten Jahr äh vierzehn Mal äh erfasst.
Vierzehn Mal. Wow.
Also da hat er, da hat er jetzt natürlich, dann verteilen sich die die Funzelner fragen natürlich nicht gleichmäßig auf die äh auf die äh auf die Stadt und die Stadt ist nicht überall gleichtig
besiedelt, also wird es natürlich einige geben, die sehr, sehr viel öfter äh erfasst wurden und einige geben die sehr, sehr viel weniger erfasst wurden, aber im Schnitt ähm,
Vierzehn Mal. Funkzellenabfrage für alle, die äh entgegen der eindringlichen Empfehlung des äh Lock
Buch, Netzpolitik, Komitees, nicht alle Folgen chronologisch bis hierher durchgehört haben, äh heißt, es wird äh an die Provider äh oder den ja die Mobilfunkprovider in einer bestimmten Region
die Anfrage gestellt, sie mögen doch bitte sagen, welche,
Mobiltelefone, zu welchem Zeitpunkt in einer bestimmten Zelle oder in einer, in einem, in einer Reihe von Zellen, die einen bestimmten Bereich abdecken eingebucht waren.
Dadurch kann man dann eben einmal erfassen, wer war alles,
zu welchem Zeitpunkt wo. Das macht man einmal bei allen Providern und da in heute in wirklich wirklich schon jeder ein Mobiltelefon in der Tasche hat kannst du dann wirklich einfach sagen, diese Personen waren in diesem Bereich.
So und jetzt hat
äh die Piratenfraktion schon vor einiger Zeit in Berlin einen Antrag eingebracht, dass der kam aber natürlich von der Opposition, konnte deswegen nicht genommen werden, deswegen hat die SPD äh,
zentrale Teile übernommen und einen eigenen Antrag daraus gemacht, damit sie nicht einen von der Opposition äh einbringen müssen.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn jetzt irgendwie auch noch akzeptieren, dass andere Leute auch gute Ideen haben.
Nein, das geht eben nicht, ne. Äh da würde halt gesagt, äh der der Senat hat jetzt oder in dieser Forderung soll,
Ne, also in diesem Antrag geht es darum, dass über die Nutzung von Funk oder über die Nutzung von äh Funkzellen erfragen, berichtet werden muss. Und zwar.
Ähm wie viele Funktionen abfragen äh beantragt und wie viele davon bewilligt wurden.
Wichtiger Punkt, da hat man dann schon mal die schöne Statistik, dass halt in der Regel keine davon, nicht, keinen Antrag abgelehnt wird. Die abgefragten Funkzellen und deren räumliche Abdeckung.
Jeweils abgefragten Zeitraum,
Die jeweils zu Grunde liegenden Straftatbestände, ne, damit du siehst, dass hier ist wahrscheinlich für jeden Handtaschenraum machen. Die Rechtsgrundlagen, auf denen diese Funkzellenabfragen bewilligt wurden.
Die Anzahl der Betroffenen Telekommunikationsanschlüsse, die Anzahl der darauf erfolgten Anschlussermittlungen,
Also du sagst ja erstmal so, welche welche Teilnehmer waren dort und dann sagst du bei denen, da wollen wir wissen, wer es auch war,
Die Anzahl der Verfahren, in denen die Funkzellenabfrage verwendet und beziehungsweise eingebracht wurde und dann da interessiert dich natürlich so,
Wirksamkeit und dann die gesamt Anzahl der Verkehrsdatensätze.
Und ob das jetzt irgendwie SMS, Telefon, Internet und so weiter ist. Und dann will das Abgeordnetenhaus zweitausendsechzehn eine Evaluierung dieser Berichtspflicht vornehmen. Und der entscheidende Punkt ist,
Sie wollen den Bürgern die Möglichkeit geben, per SMS informiert zu werden. Ja, das wird natürlich nicht sofort, ist nicht irgendwie so.
Hallo vom Zählen nachfrage, denn die findet ja erst einige Tage später statt und dann ist das gesamte Ermittlungsverfahren, da darf dann keiner gewarnt werden. Aber wenn das dann alles abgeschlossen ist, sollst du eine SMS bekommen
Übrigens, wir haben an dem und dem Tag äh um die und die Uhrzeit festgestellt, dass sie bei der Arbeit waren oder so, ne? Oder dass sie in diesem Ort waren.
Und äh es wird also jetzt mit diesem Antrag der Senat aufgefordert, eine ein SMS Informationssystem umzusetzen.
Und da können dann die Bürger über SMS ihren Wunsch dokumentieren, dass sie über die Erhebung ihrer Daten im Rahmen einer funktionellen Abfrage informiert werden wollen. Das heißt, ähm,
quasi dieser impliziten Annahme. Ach Quatsch, wir wir erkennen nicht, warum die Bürger darüber informiert werden wollen würden.
Kannst du dann quasi entgegentreten, wenn du sagst, übrigens, wenn ihr mein Handy äh in irgendwie mitm Datenschleppnetz ortet, dann sagt ihr mal bitte Bescheid.
Und jetzt äh wird geprüft von der Senatsverwaltung, wie man diesen äh ähm diesen Forderungen.
Äh wie man diesen Forderungen entsprechen kann.
Also wie man das technisch realisieren kann. Ja. Mhm. Vielleicht drüber nachgedacht, was das so auslösen könnte,
sagen wir mal eine entsprechende Funkzellenabfrage findet jetzt statt. Gibt jetzt so zwei Szenarios, so dieses,
Szenario, äh Auto hat gebrannt,
Ganz genau, wie groß die Zahlen waren von abgefragten Leuten ja, was was bewirkt das dann, wenn man äh ach so, warte mal, das ist Opt-In, ne? Also man muss sozusagen explizit sagen,
ich will solche SMSer auch haben.
Ja, das ist der ärgerliche Teil davon, ja.
Ja, na ja, stell dir mal vor, es wäre halt nicht Opt-In. Was dann passieren würde.
Ja, dann würden halt die ganzen Rentner, die irgendwie eine SMS bekommen haben, ihre Enkel anrufen und sagen, irgendwie die verfolgen mich.
Genau, sie sind hinter mir her.
Ja. Äh klar, das ist äh ist nicht so ein äh nicht so ein einfacher ähm nicht so eine einfache Sache.
So und die Leute, die dann aber Opt-in machen, ist ja auch schon mal eine interessante Datenbank. Mhm.
All die Leute, die sozusagen, ach so, es kümmert sich. Das ist so wie ein bisschen wie dieser Robinson-Liste. Ich will keine Werbung, aber ich möchte gerne äh gesagt bekommen, wenn ich überwacht werde. Ah, so einer so. Aha.
Ja, natürlich, ähm der diese diese Berichtssache ist ähm, denke ich, da auch nur noch so das Kirschchen oben auf der Sahnehaube. Ähm.
Statistiken, dass natürlich wirklich viel interessanter.
Mit den mit den Statistiken ist der interessante Teil.
Dürfte sich jetzt schon die Hände reiben.
Ja, da wirst du, da brauchst du gar kein Open Data City Firmen am Ende diese Zahlen zu sehen und zu sagen, habt ihr nicht den Arsch auf? Also das kannst du dir ungefähr vorstellen, wie ähm.
Wie.
Ist das eine. Schön dreidimensional visualisiert ist das andere.
Ach so, ja, ja, das, das kann man dann auch noch sehen, ne? Aber das da gab's ja sogar schon einige. Ähm aber also ne, dieser dieser ähm.
Ich denke, dass dieser Antrag das Richtige ist, weil die richtige, der richtige Weg ist, diesem.
Bei diesem Ermittlungswerkzeug eine sinnvolle ähm.
Ja verhältnismäßigkeitseinschätzung vorzunehmen, um es dann in einem zweiten Schritt auch vernünftig gesetzlich zu äh regulieren.
Und das finde ich schon äh erwähnenswert und positiv. Ja, dass sowas äh stattfindet.
Gut.
Weitere Informationen könnten äh demnächst die Welt äh fluten, weil Lengreen mag jetzt wohl keine Stone-Dokumente mehr lesen.
Äh äh Glan Green World hat jetzt in einem in einem ähm in einem Interview mit dem mit der Weltpresse, dem Münchner Merkur.
Äh gesagt, ja also er ähm er selbst äh
sei also jetzt auch inzwischen mal langsam also er nennt nicht diesen Begriff, aber man merkt das ja jetzt auch einfach ausgebrannt ist und sagt, er hat sich irgendwie jetzt seit zwei Jahren damit auseinandergesetzt und wenn er mal irgendwie äh auch nur einen Tag,
nicht daran arbeitet, bekommt er irgendwie ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil er gerade nicht die die Aufklärung der Menschheit vorantreibt und.
Die Snowden-Dokumente, die ihm ja überlassen wurden. Genau. Mhm.
Genau. Und ähm hat gesagt, dass er jetzt die journalistische,
journalistische Arbeit mit diesen Dokumenten auf eine breitere Basis äh bringen möchte, in dem in New York,
Ein Datenraum eingerichtet wird, wo dann Journalisten ermöglicht werden soll, äh sich mit diesen Dokumenten auseinanderzusetzen.
Jetzt äh titeln dann ähm viele unter anderem Netzpolitik Org. Er wurde auch Zeit,
Endlich stellt äh Greenworld diese Dokumente anderen Journalisten zur Verfügung. Äh das halte ich für ein bisschen äh übertrieben. Wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie viele Journalisten damit inzwischen schon arbeiten
Es ist nicht so, als hätte Glenwoll jetzt die letzten zwei Jahre da irgendwie gesessen und keinem was abgegeben.
Ganz im Gegenteil, wir haben äh ganze Rechercheteams beim Spiegel, wir haben ganze Rechercheteams Bier wie äh Süddeutsche und NDR, die da irgendwie zusammenarbeiten.
Guardian, New York Times.
Der Guardian ähm ja also bei den,
den verschiedenen Medienhäusern liegen die Dokumente oder große Teile dieser Dokumente, ja? Ähm.
Das das äh ist ähm,
nicht nicht gerechtfertigt da zu sagen, dass der Mann irgendwie da drauf gesessen hätte oder so, ja? Ähm.
Das ist der, der erste Punkt. Andererseits ähm ist es natürlich, es wird jetzt quasi, man könnte,
Daraus schließen, dass jetzt so das das kommt, ne, also der der letzte das das letzte große Abfackeln des äh Feuerwerks, ja.
Und das dann äh es deutet sich also an, dass diese Snowden Geschichte langsam ähm ihr Ende finden wird.
Zumindest die großen Enthüllungen.
Haben sie nicht irgendwie noch vor Alze, nicht allzu langer Zeit gesagt, da kommen die großen Hammer kommen noch?
Ja werden noch größer, da werden noch einige kommen, klar. Also ich sage jetzt nicht, das ist jetzt vorbei. Ich äh würde also Glen Green World ähm,
wird der jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein abgefrühstückten äh Haufen Knochen noch hinlegen und sagen, hier, das sind die Reste, die könnt ihr haben. Ne, der hat ja schon andere äh klare äh,
Ziele und Ideale in seiner journalistischen journalistischen äh Tätigkeit hier.
Aber also wir werden's, also die, ich denke, diese Meldung wird eben ein bisschen überbewertet
Es ist natürlich schön, dass ihr sagt, okay, ich persönlich möchte mich jetzt da langsam auch einfach rausziehen, weil ich das äh weil ich mich anderen Themen widmen möchte und weil mir das irgendwie zu viel, äh weil mich das auch zu stark belastet
das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Der Mann hat eine Menge durchgemacht in letzter Zeit und hat äh wirklich
keine schönen Nachrichten schreiben können für für wirklich eine lange Zeit. Und vielleicht möchte der jetzt halt irgendwie so auch was mal was was weiß ich so.
Naturlandschaften in Peru, irgendwas.
Block. Ja, Reiseblog, Reise oder Kochblock würde ich, würde ich empfehlen. Ja.
Ich kann mir das auch wirklich gut vorstellen. Man weiß ja nicht, wie da sonst so drauf so ein bisschen abonniert zu sein eigentlich auf solche Themen, dass der sich nun wirklich jetzt komplett äh davon abwendet,
Weiß ich nicht. Aber vielleicht sieht ihr auch einfach die Notwendigkeit, einfach mal eine andere Perspektive darauf zu gewinnen, die es so bisher noch nicht gab.
Ja, es wird auf jeden Fall ähm.
Ja, also ich ich glaube, dass es das wird jetzt nicht der große Knall sein, weil, wie gesagt, seit Jahren schon andere ähm Redaktionen mit diesen Dokumenten arbeiten. Das ist nicht so, als hätte da jetzt irgendwie äh Greenworld das den Daumen drauf gehalten oder so was.
Interessant ist aber in diesem Datenraum, da werden sie natürlich auch ein sehr interessantes Regime führen müssen, wen sie da überhaupt reinlassen, ne. Weil die ersten, die da morgens äh vor der Tür stehen, sind natürlich die Geheimdienste. Die sagen hallo.
Journalistin.
Ich bin äh seit kurzem, ich wollte mal gucken.
Ja, na ja gut, ich denke, das wird dann erstmal so ein kleines Social Network von äh Bekannten, Journalisten sein, wenn die sich das dann keine Ahnung, Events sehen.
Nachher schleppen, da ein bissel blauer Daten raus und dann zeige ich dir.
So geht's ja nicht,
Gut Linus, ich glaube, äh jetzt sollten wir langsam mal hier zum Ende kommen. Heute sind wir ein bisschen knapp dran.
Ja. Ja.
Ne? Nicht hier so epische Sendungen und all das irgendwie stundenlang. Na ja, die Stunde kriegen wir trotzdem noch voll. Aber jetzt, jetzt haben wir irgendwie, jetzt haben wir überhaupt nicht so richtig über Überwachung gesprochen.